[Música]
[Aplausos]
aí eu estou me inspirar como podem ver
mas eu sou bióloga marinha desde 2009 e
há uns tempos e tem uma exposição
fotográfica do fotógrafo da national
geographic ideal sartori e porém com uma
frase com skin todas as criaturas
grandes e pequenas são valiosas
magníficas e merecem viver e existir e
eu acho que esta frase realmente escrevo
um sentimento dos biólogos pela vida eu
e minha irmã desde pequenas que
brincávamos na quinta do meu avô como
podem ver a minha mãe tá linda foto e
minha irmã gêmea e ainda estamos belgas
marinhas em nós passávamos horas e horas
a verdes formigas cães gatos ou velhas e
foi um pouco por aí que nasceu nosso
amor pela biologia mas também neste
processo
sabemos que a natureza está vulnerável
devido à atividade uma outra específica
somos nós os humanos
eu acho que foi também um pouco isso que
pensou a um cientista o pouco crédito
sempre foi prémio nobel da química em 95
que o propôs que o mundo entrou numa
nova época geológica o antropoceno ou
seja época em que o homem altera
significativamente o meio ambiente ele
haja um novo para o período da história
mais recente após a segunda guerra
mundial em que a taxa de mudança
realmente muito elevado importante para
chamar grande saturação
ou seja as tendências socioeconômicas
como o crescimento populacional e os
recursos energéticos e da água é muito
fácil assim como a emissão de gases com
efeito de estufa ea destruição dos
habitats e isso prova que o homem tem
capacidade de modificar os processos
ecológicos e portanto nós agora
perguntamos será que estamos perante uma
crise de biodiversidade e eu falei com o
mano já passou por cinco extinções em
massa e nós estamos atualmente a atriz
está a observar a uma festa extinção em
massa em que a taxa de extinção está 100
vezes acima da taxa
o casal ou seja nós perguntamos será que
estamos perante um ponto viragem na
trajetória de vida na terra
e o fato é que se olharmos para os dados
da união internacional para a
conservação da natureza
percebemos que por exemplo 40% dos
anfíbios estão ameaçados 30% de várias
vários grupos marinha estão ameaçados
inclusivamente a urtiga noite foi
publicada quer perca 15 37% das espécies
terrestres pode distinguir até 2050
somente devido ao impacto das alterações
climáticas mas nós perguntamos ok mas os
oceanos cobrem mais nenhum contato
planeta o que está acontecendo os
oceanos
eu trabalhei com os oceanos absorvem
grande parte do calor e do dióxido de
carbono produzido também eles vão sofrer
e estão a sofrer já um aquecimento uma
significação e também uma grande
freqüência de eventos extremos como
ondas de calor é importante nós temos
que perceber qual é unidade dos
organismos marinhos das alterações
climáticas e para isso temos feito
estudos de segurança e térmica e
flexibilidade fisiológica que já foram
muito úteis porque nos ajudarão a
determinar pegamos um ranking de um
grande vulnerabilidade dos organismos às
alterações climáticas por exemplo temos
aqui o caso de alguns peixes da costa
portuguesa em que nós percebemos que
hugo chávez por exemplo são mais
favoráveis do que as tenha e através
desse estudo percebemos também que o que
acontece é que não assine mais quente a
taxa metabólica dos organismos é maior
porque deus tem um gasto energético
maior e muitas vezes ainda no suor
também quando a temperatura é muito
falada isso tem impacto em nível da
produção investimento e da abundância
das populações e com o empate promovem a
nível da disponibilidade dos cursos um
evento muito óbvio do impacto das
alterações climáticas e por exemplo uma
grande barreira de coral da austrália em
que zonas do calor causando da unidade
mas se vê por exemplo em 2016 30 por
cento dos corais morreram e isso não é
caso único por exemplo os a vantagem das
florestas do que o corintiano macroalgas
marinhas também estão incluindo muitas
entoado mas temos também que ver
parte não só direitos na fisiologia do
animal são também direto e para vocês
perceberem este sequer ouviram falar
desta notícia dos pingüins da antártida
há pouco tempo a verdade é que elas não
conseguiram produzir durante os últimos
três anos devido à instabilidade do gelo
marinho e portanto a pergunta que fica é
será que elas têm hábitos alternativas
produzir e qual é que a durabilidade
sabe tarde passa as alterações
climáticas
isso pra não ensinar que por exemplo os
cardumes de peixes podem se distribuir
devido ao aquecimento oceânico e o que
aconteceu em 2017 que os pingüins
adultos moravam mais tempo encontrar
alimento e ovário juiz domingos que
morreram a forma importante nós
perguntamos com os cientistas como é que
podemos conservar essa biodiversidade e
eu acho que é uma ideia muito importante
que temos que ter evidenciado é uma rede
não as pessoas que estão isoladas uma
espécie foi afetada as outras também são
e nós como humanos também estamos dentro
desta rede importante temos tudo em três
e manter ou a agora o que eu digo é que
temos que pensar para a conservação e
será que queremos evitar totalmente a
mudança ecológica e manter as espécies e
ecossistemas que constam hoje estamos
tão mal que mudança inevitável e temos
que ter um papel interventivo temos que
facilitar a adaptação das espécies
destas pressões ambientais
é verdade que não há uma solução global
muitas vezes para os problemas de
conservação tem que ser uma solução
muitas vezes local e já existe alguma
solução que digamos que é inovadora mas
também é um pouco controversa evolução
de pimental numa fase inicial uma
evolução documental nós tentamos
perceber qual é que a dinâmica evolutiva
da espécie tentar perceber se ela
resiste ao longo das gerações ela
sobrevive e quais são os mecanismos
fisiológicos em lecco acho que lhe
permitem sobreviver e podemos talvez a
partir daí isso precisamos de uma de um
plano de conservação mais adequado ou
não mas se nós acharmos na evolução
experimental e usaram existe como uma
ferramenta direta de conservação as
passamos a ter uma coisa que se chama
evolução assistida ou seja não
que queremos potenciar um atributo psi
phi como por exemplo a tolerância e
térmica ou seja nós ainda estamos no
começo mas vocês pensei nisso como uma
espécie de criar uma versão beta do
animal uma opção mais resistentes
isso nós pagamos nos indivíduos mais
resistente ser produzimos e se fazemos
isto ao longo de gerações até que temos
uma população muito mais consistentes do
que tínhamos inicialmente ea verdade é
que isto está atualmente já ser aplicado
na austrália por causa dos problemas da
mortalidade negócio e do coral
os cientistas estão neste momento é
criar hurlar estruturantes para mais
tarde tentar economizar os habitats e
repor em zonas mortas
agora isto tem sido essencialmente foi
do nível de invertebrados marinhos
porque eu estou mais fáceis de manipular
em laboratório e porque são realmente os
bebês estruturantes do ecossistema noção
espécies a base da cadeia alimentar
mas realmente nós temos que pensar será
que isto que queremos é que existe uma
solução da sala de emergência assim que
todos os cientistas filme em pânico
o papel lhe disse que nós vamos fazer e
realmente isso não é que o que nós
queremos provar a nossa natureza o que
nós queremos é que nós não tem não
tínhamos que chegar a este ponto
nós temos que mudar o nosso
comportamento nós temos que pensar se
realmente vale a pena de garotas ponte
importante nós temos que pensar mudar
nosso comportamento é essencial nós
temos que educar as gerações futuras
para valorizar a natureza e tudo o que
ela nos dá
nós temos que o cycloar nós temos que
limpar as praias nós temos que consumir
produtos sustentáveis e lembro vocês
podem pensar que eles são poucas coisas
e até podem ser das poucas coisas e
penalizados
* milhões de pessoas podem realmente
transformar o mundo e é isso que vocês
têm de pensar ea mensagem que eu quero
que vocês pensem em casa e como é que
criam de escrever a história do amanhã
tudo pode pender nova apenas que nós
podemos melhorar o mundo
obrigado
[Aplausos]